random sub time
i'm going to feel bad about this one
but here we go
[Music]
playing the
the nuzo larsen
and now
now i begins
we'll see if emblem tries to punish me
because emblem probably knows what's
going on here
i guess i could pre-move this
you swiss man of war a thousand bits
so the challenge is to play the beach
cafe opening
really have having to double check my
spelling
so far i'm controlling some squares
i'm gonna have to scroll through the
notation to see everything
after this game i will actually play a
serious game i'll try and be very
instructive and
maybe even mute alerts so i can fully
focus
but this game
we have the beach
now it's time for the cafe
i'm so kind just developing
like a good human
okay
so
there's a few ways to build the cafe
currently we have the beechka or beechka
i should probably play f3 and then e4
and it's nice to
yeah to keep out the bishop
because if i play f4 e4 and then i just
hang a pawn
wow so beach cafe leads to pawns on all
light squares
i guess i could have like played
different variations like have the pawn
on b4 h4 but
wait
how do you spell cafe e okay
so this is a beach cafe opening
now i switch to serious chess and this
is where
i have to try and stay focused and
recover from
my lack of development
hey thank you bought my amazing
boyfriend nathan some merch because he
loves you and i love him smile oh that's
so nice
skeleton nathan
okay serious chess time
i have a bishop
um nicely placed on the diagonal
i think emblem has improved since we
first played it
emblem used to be 1576
and now emblem is over 2 000
just by probably watching the stream and
playing me a bunch
yeah i'll reopen challenges after this
game
it's an interesting move
i mean i should take
allowing a queen trade
oh also along bishop b4 but then knight
c3
a funny comment from shadow b
my ten-year-old just found out that i
got to play you on stream
[Music]
his response
wait so now the whole internet has seen
your terrible chess
that's kind of savage
but hopefully it was a learning
opportunity
and sometimes the best way to learn is
to
expose your mistakes to the world
wow resilient gaining
[Music]
600 points
yeah ratings fluctuate
so
it's normal to
bounce up and down
like the stock market
okay so we're actually getting a
somewhat playable and solid position for
both sides
knight h5 was interesting trying to
target the square but
now it's covered
i'll be going for g4
maybe even still g4
i want to open the g file
it takes takes
maybe i keep pushing
i might have to put this whole stream on
youtube
i don't know like how i'll chop it up
there's been so many like weird moments
okay so beginning to find some activity
and there's quadruple fork potential
[Music]
if the knight lands on e6
[Music]
i mean g5 i think is the way to go
this is turning into a nice beach cafe
oh can i sack the knight
i want to play this
move this move's not good though
let's be a bit more
[Music]
picky with how i deal with things
i play this move
my grook g1 g6
play rook g1
does the beach cafe serve eggs i'm ready
for the upcoming serious game don't be
one like magnus when he goes 25 moves
deep let's go
okay
i i don't know if i can
imitate magnus in that regard
maybe i can go like 10 or 15 moves deep
i really wanted to play c5 to enable
bishop c4
but uh
okay
i'll play
the h4
and block has a solid structure here
this pawn is a bit undefended
wow
okay i have to play this
i think i'm still objectively worse here
b3 is asking bishop g7 move 18
move 18
ah
yeah bishop g7 would win
two pawns and a rook for the two minor
pieces
but then i would lose my only developed
pieces so
[Music]
i should have considered it at the very
least
but even if i saw it i'm not sure if i
would have played it
because these are my best pieces
okay sadly
yeah we're gonna trade
i should have considered bishop g2 there
okay so there's h5
h5 there's bishop h5
this is weirdly tricky
i think i'll start with this move
bishop e4
i think i'll just play this
but i don't like the idea
man of knight c5 so i was thinking
bishop c3 king b2
realizing there's there's a lot to worry
about here
maybe i'll just trade
this is my bad bishop anyway
actually trading makes a lot of sense
because after takes takes knight c5 king
c2 there's idea of rook h1
h5 takes in rook h7
i have to start preparing myself for the
serious game
now king c2
connecting the rooks
oh i missed a funny line
i'm still threatening it though
oh that's a really funny line too
okay i'm gonna have to wait to see
if black allows it
whoa it's anonymous
are you anonymous gifting 20 subs
that's so kind
i really appreciate that
okay going
knight c5 is a very fine move
um
so now of 94 i take
and if
uh if pawn takes i win the bishop
but i think the knight has to move back
i'm really hoping we get to see the
funny line
ah no funny line
i'll win the bishop
i'll share it after the game because i i
missed a really cool idea to take on e6
i could share it now um
yeah i'm sorry king c2 i missed takes
takes bishop d5
oh maybe it didn't work
so after bishop a3 there's c5
never mind
okay so black's going for counter play
d2 is a threat
if i cover d2 idea rook f1
vindictive asking can you make a youtube
series where you win against subs going
up the leeches rating ladder
does that mean i would like make a new
account and it would be similar to like
a a speed run
with leech us i have to be careful
i'm not like violating tos
because if i make a new account and play
really games and
uh i don't want to be like smurfing
people
i know i can do it on chess.com though
yeah last time i talked to leachat's
admins
they didn't have like a a system
for refunding points
even if it's like a
approved account
but
yeah more likely to do on chess.com it
would be a i think educational
concept
okay so i have a lot of discoveries here
none of the discoveries look so
appetizing
yeah sometimes if it doesn't look
appetizing you have to
season it with some more spices and
sugar
before you consume it
so now i want to take on g6
wow
i'm trying to find the most efficient
way of mating
okay i'll start by taking
and the king has no moves but i'm not
oh there's this funny move
oh no my knight
yeah so there's a speed run
[Music]
and there's a climbing the raiding
ladder
hey okay so this is force mate
uh the the bishop the pawn the rook and
the other rook combined quite nicely
good game emblem
yeah sorry to have played such a meme
opening
we had the beach cafe
for those that are just joining
if we scroll through the notation
i'm not proud to share this but
it does spell out beach
cafe